hello everyone the sink sealed cups has
just started two days ago and while
we're waiting for Kasparov to join them
in the rapid and blade section RN made
sure that even the classical section
doesn't go without fireworks and this
game is played in round one of the
single class 2017 and Aragon shows why
they call him the most creative top-10
player in the world so let's see the
game Aragon is white and the young upon
me ah she is black we have Knight to f3
by Onion Knight to f6
we have c4 c5 Knight to c3 the
symmetrical English opening d5c capture
some d5 Knight captures on d5 and e3 we
have night chapter song b3 c3 be
captures on c3 and g6 and this is
already where Eragon really starts to
mix things up
he plays h4 we have Bishop to g7 and now
h5 going for breaking this ventured out
structure with a Knight to c6 and here
is Erin as the idea of h4 and h5 he
plays Bishop to a3 and this is a very
interesting because he allows a young to
play and the Queen to a5 another Queen
is attacking this Bishop and also pony
ah she is kind of threatening to capture
this C pawn with his bishop and go for
some sort of an attack but this was
arrogance idea he plays a rook to h4 and
although it's another not often a good
idea to you know just push our side pawn
and then develop the rook this way he
actually makes it work because he is
this rock page 4 move actually is
protecting this Bishop on a3 if the
Queen would capture the bishop then
simply rook to a4 and the Queen strap we
can just check it out here and oh funky
ways to protect the bishop definitely
so after root page for pneumonia she
played Bishop to d7 and we have Queen to
b3 and now in apamea she castles and
nopony is offering his
b7 born here and after quite a you know
a short while Allen plays H captures and
g6 we have H captures on g6 and Queen
captures on b7 and after having a place
this I played this Queen captures n b7
move and if I'm Nia she well she thought
more than half an hour and what the play
is next move
so obviously this pawn sacrifice was a
you know quite a bluff in the Iranian
called it very nicely if you look at
this position the computer is suggesting
nice to be 8 here and then threatening
Bishop to c6
but obviously an ammonia she didn't have
this planned as like I said he took more
than half an hour for his next move so
we have rook F to rue casa da protecting
this bishop we have Queen to a6 now
offering to exchange Queens
we have Bishop captures on c3 and as we
should cannot be captured if d captures
on c3 Queen Catherine c3 okay we can
just show it then this rook is going
down so obviously after Bishop captures
on c3 re and just capture the Queen
Queen captures an a5 Bishop captures on
a file and now Bishop captures on c5 and
okay it's in somewhat of an equal ending
but our engine is a pawn up you know
that b7 pawn that that's in it for me I
she tried to bluff it away so we have a
Bishop to e6 and now Bishop to b5
attacking that nice that is unprotected
on c6 we have a knight Knight to e5 and
now Knight to d4 rook rook to d5
attacking the bishop and Bishop captures
on e7 and here a Iranian is already
threatening Bishop to f6 and rope the h8
checkmate so this has to be stopped
so King to g7 by a pony ah she and we
have F 4 and this F 4 is a wonderful
move as it kicks the nice and then this
c6 square will be available for the
bishop to to me
double attack on the rooks so we have a
knife to 1987 and now at five
we have Bishop captures an f5 and now
Bishop to c6 attacking this is a rockin
rockin d5 and rook on a eight so we have
a rook to e5 and now Knight captures an
f5 first with check you know just
trading down G captures an f5 and now
Bishop to g5 just to get his Bishop out
of harm's way here since it was attacked
and upon me a she plays King to g6
attacking the bishop once again and now
our and simply placed bishop to f4 and
now our onion is attacking this rook on
a a this rock on f4 and the undefended
night and b7 so an epic Nia place
erupted to DA defending the knight and
well R&M just captures the knight and d7
removing the defender of this rope and
e5 we have rook
i roped the c5 and this bishop this
light square bishop is now attacked and
if it moved the pneumonia she could
capture here on d2 and there's some
trouble but our engine stops this
immediately he plays route 88 86 check
we have King g7 and now simply rook the
d6 defending this Bishop and also
protecting v2 so we have a bishop the c7
attacking this rook and also this bishop
if the rook moves and RM simply plays
rook to c6 and in this position upon me
ah she resigned his double attacking
this bishop here and well this rock is
obviously attacked and of course one
more important thing
karenann is up a piece so there's really
no point in playing this only Palmilla
she resigns and a very nice very nice
game only 29 moves so you know always
nice to see a 29 move game when talked
among the top 10 players are playing and
yeah this definitely shows that that h4
h5 and rook the a4 idea why they
consider iron young to be the most
creative top 10 player so yeah a
wonderful game and we'll see how our
nana plays this tournament he did
couple of strong tournaments he played
in before this one and yeah hope you
enjoyed this game you can check two of
my previous videos here and that's it
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon